Files are stored in something called the Hadoop Distributed
File System. Which everyone just refers to as HDFS.
As a developer, this looks very much like a
regular file system. The kind you're used to working
with on a standard machine. But it's helpful to
understand what's going on behind the scenes. So that's
what we're going to talk about here. Imagine we're
going to store a file called mydata.txt. In HDFS.
This file is 150 megabytes. When a file
is loaded into HDFS, it's split into chunks which
we call blocks. Each block is pretty big. The
default is 64 megabytes. Each block is given a
unique name, which is BLK, an underscore, and
a large number. We'll call ours block one, two,
and three. And in our case the first block
is 64 megabytes. The second block is 64 megabytes.
The third block is the remaining 22 megabytes, to make
up our 150 megabyte file. As the file is uploaded
to HDFS, each block will get stored on one node
in the cluster. There's a Damon, or piece of software,
running on each of the machines in the cluster, called
the DataNode. Now clearly we need to know which blocks
make up the original file. And that's handled by a
separate machine, running the Damon called the NameNode. The information
stored on the NameNode is known as the Metadata. That's fine
as far as it goes, but there are some problems with
this. Take a look at the diagram and see if you
can spot where we might run into trouble. For example, let's
say there was network failure between the nodes, or a disk
failure on a DataNode. Do you think it's an issue that
not all of the DataNodes are used to store data? Or
could it be a problem that that the block sizes differ?
Two of them are 64 megabytes, but one was only 22 megabytes. Finally, do
you think it'd be a problem if we had a disk failure on the NameNode?